this is a production of Cornell
University
this is a short PowerPoint presentation
on getting used to using the nice pad
website to get label information I hope
that you find it helpful so that you can
fill out your Master Gardener sheets in
order to complete the training in a few
weeks so the first thing to do is to go
to the nice pad website the website
address is listed up here and in your
handout but you can also just google
nice pad and it and you will come right
to this website what you want to do in
order to get a label is to look to the
where I've circled it in yellow under
pesticides information and press
products that will bring you to the
search engine part of the nice pad
website the search engine is very nice
you can search by different categories
you can look for insecticides with a
specific lower toxicity level you can
find out if a product is restricted or
not it's very very powerful
but for us what we're just going to do
we're trying to find a particular label
we're going to enter the label number
we're going to enter the product EPA
registration number and to try to find
the label so what you do is you where
I've circled in red product EPA
registration number we're going to use
that pull down menu to choose New York
product number
so you pull down New York product number
and leave it there and then enter your
EPA registration number it can have the
dash number so where it says four two
six nine seven dash sixty put the dashes
in then slide your mouse down to the
bottom of the search page and to find
that search button you won't be able to
see it when you're putting in the EPA
number it's sort of off screen so to
slide the website screen down so you can
find that search button and then press
that if if it works you'll see this card
so to speak that shows the the
information of the product that you have
put you put the EPA number in for so in
this case I put in the number for safer
soap very common insecticide and the
card shows you a few things one that has
of course the name of the product the
newer product number or the EPA number
the company and whether it's restricted
use or not in this case there's no
restrictions which means that homeowners
can buy this product and use it if it
was restricted in New York that means
only certified pesticide applicators
could use that product the second
circles
it says Li use yes and that means the
product can be used in Long Island in
some some products leach to to quickly
through the soil and the sandy soils of
Long Island you could have a potential
for groundwater pollution so there are
some chemicals that you cannot use in
Long Island you can use them here in
upstate New York but not in Long Island
so that will tell you that in the square
there's a button called more and you
press that to get the label once you
press that another more detailed card
will come up with more information about
your product it has information about
what type of product in this case it's
an insecticide it's used in home gardens
and ornamental plantings and I want to
point out that it also will have the
signal warning in this case it's warning
it might be caution warning or danger or
I guess poison and the most toxic of
pesticides so that's a good thing to be
able to find if you want to get the
label you press the most recent label
date in this case it's four three nine
2017 so press that the blue highlighted
numbers for the for the most recent
label for this product and what will
come up is a the picture of the label
for safer soap you probably if you had
chosen this product to look at you would
be seeing what's on the left and on the
upper right is the back side of the
label but inside once you purchase a
product to kind of peel away this part
and you see the actual fine print so to
speak of the label how it's used on what
insects the application rates etc in
this case you'll be your eyes would be
better than mine if I could if you could
read that so here's a little tip in
order to read the fine print of a label
you want to swipe your mouse to the
right and sort of magically these three
buttons will appear if you press the
plus button it increases the font size
though you'll be able to read this fine
print and I actually like to use this
because quite frankly a lot of labels
they have to squeeze so much information
into them that the actual physical label
the paper label that's
part of the cat the product is the types
really small so it is really nice to be
able to have this larger be able to
really read it you could print it out
and be able to study the label because
remember the label is the law you have
to apply a chemical according to the
label whether it's organic or not and so
that part of what we want you to learn
is how to quickly access the most
important parts of information for the
label what's the first aid what's the
environmental hazards what's the product
what kind of PPE protective equipment
that you need to wear in order to
protect yourself when using the chemical
those kind of things so we just want you
to be familiar with the aspects of a
label specifically with safety in mind I
hope you have enjoyed this PowerPoint
and good luck searching nice pad
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu